inmuebles que se derrumban
deslizamientos de terreno y edificios
inundados Estas son las imágenes de las
lluvias que sacuden desde el inicio de
la semana King una región que tiene más
de 30 millones de habitantes es uno de
los desastres naturales más mortíferos
ocurridos en el país desde el inicio del
año ya se reportaron varios muertos y
heridos en la ciudad de Bowl long las
lluvias fueron particularmente fuertes
el martes y obligaron varios de sus
habitantes a evacuar la zona hacia las
seis de la mañana el agua estaba a un
metro por debajo del puente luego entre
las 7 y 10 y las 7:20 la crecida
torrencial empezó a sumergir la calzada
a las 7:30 el nivel del agua ya superaba
el metro por encima de la calzada el
gobierno un grupo de trabajo a la región
este miércoles para supervisar el
trabajo de los socorristas china lleva
semanas sufriendo olas de calor extremas
particularmente en la capital Beijing y
que se acompañan ahora de lluvias
torrenciales en el sur las autoridades
advirtieron que el país se prepara para
sufrir múltiples catástrofes naturales
en julio como chifones o inundaciones el
presidente
priorizar la protección de la seguridad
y de la propiedad de las personas